und das ist so Maximilian K jetzt
inzwischen Spitzenkandidat der Partei
für die Wahl zum Europäischen Parlament
und nach dem was als Ergebnis im Juni
2024 zu erwarten ist auch ganz sicher
mit dabei sie waren ja schon bisher im
Europäischen Parlament Mitglied gewesen
in der Fraktion Identität und Demokratie
zwei Drittel haben für sie gestimmt ist
das Ergebnis okay für sie hätten sich
noch mehr gewünscht an Zustimmung hier
vom von der europawahlversammlung müssen
Sie die AFD ist ja bekannt für ehrliche
Ergebnisse also diese 100%, wie bei CDU
und SPD haben wir nicht das ist das
schaden da AFD und ich denke dass auch
nach den teilweise von außen
herangetragenen Kritiken an mich ist das
ein überwältigendes Ergebnis und das
zeigt dass sich die AFD eben nicht mehr
verrückt machen lässt von irgendwelchen
anfallenden sondern Kuss hält und das
ist das Wichtigste viele in der AFD
wollen ja eigentlich das Europäische
Parlament abschaffen sehen Sie das genau
so oder sozusagen als Job Killer in
eigener Sache unterwegs zu sein na wir
wollen die wir wollen eine komplett
andere Europapolitik wir wollen nicht
wieder diese Union in der wir ein
bürokratisches Monstrum sehen dass eben
negative Folgen für Deutschland bringt
wir wollen einen Bund europäischer
Nationen und
dir die die solange wir die EU haben
brauchen wir aber dieses Parlament weil
wir nur so da die Anliegen der Bürger
direkt in Brüssel vertreten können also
insofern wir wollen die EU insgesamt
umbauen aber in der jetzigen EU brauchen
wir dieses Parlament weil es uns die
Chance gibt direkt in Brüssel aktiv zu
werden sie wollen es aber trotzdem
mittelfristig abwickeln weil wir wollen
eine komplett andere Struktur der
Europapolitik solange wir diese Struktur
nicht haben ist das ja unser Hebel aktiv
zu sein also so diese vor fünf Jahren im
im Programm stehende Forderung findet
sich in dem jetzigen Entwurf nicht
es war ursprünglicher geplant dass
Norbert Kleinwächter gegen sie hier
antritt bei der Wahl zum Spitzenkandidat
der hat eine eine Entgegnung
veröffentlicht jetzt auf ihre
Buchveröffentlichung Politik von rechts
im Verlag des neurechten Vordenkers Götz
Kubitschek also nochmal der Titel
Politik von rechts und er wirft ihnen
vor dass sie Verfassung Rechtsstaat
Kontrolle der staatlichen Macht
Menschenrechte im westlichen sind
abschaffen wollen wenn das so wäre passt
das ja eigentlich gar nicht zu ihren
politischen Ambitionen denn sie
kandidieren ja bekanntlich fürs
Europäische Parlament und nicht für den
chinesischen Volkskongress oder die Duma
wir schauen Sie ich kenne diese wiederum
aber ich schlage einfach vorlesen sie
mein Buch und dann schauen Sie ob diese
Probleme die da verfasst wurde in
irgendeiner Form rechtlich begründet
oder überhaupt begründet ist tatsächlich
oder nicht sie werden feststellen das
sind aus böswilligen textverkürzungen
und Verfälschung zusammen fabrizierte
Vorwürfe
ich halte sie nicht mal würdig dass man
darüber diskutiert mein Buch spricht für
sich es ist jetzt zweiter Auflage wird
es bereits massiv verkauft man kann
sehen was es heißt politische Antworten
von rechts zu geben man muss nicht mehr
nur links und Mittel sein auch die
politische Rechte kann was bieten und
insofern wäre jetzt die Frage hat was
konkret bitte sie da liest bitte krass
Politik von rechts und nicht irgendeinem
im Internet kursierende Polemik dagegen
von sowas lassen wir uns gar nicht mehr
beeindrucken stelle ich die Nachfrage
also Verfassung Rechtsstaatlichkeit
Gewaltenteilung Menschenrechte das sind
die Wesens Elemente des Grundgesetzes
die stehen für Sie über jeder
staatlichen Macht die auch kontrolliert
werden muss
in dem Buch steht drin es gibt ein
verfassungsstandard wir stehen zur
Verfassung es wird widerlegt die gesamte
reichsbürgerideologie wir bekennen uns
zur persönlichen Freiheit und zum
Individuum wir schreiben welche Rolle
und auslegungsmaßstäbe für
Menschenrechte gelten also wenn Sie den
Wortlaut nehmen weiß ich überhaupt nicht
wie man das missverstehen kann gut also
sie stehen zu 100% zum Grundgesetz das
war ja die Frage
ich habe Jura studiert ich bin
Rechtsanwalt ich bin Abgeordneter ich
habe noch nie irgendwie eine Strafe bin
noch nie strafrechtlichen Erscheinung
getreten also allein dass ich mich dafür
rechtfertigen muss oder erklären muss ob
ich nun zur Verfassung stehe stellen Sie
die Fragen den Grünen auch gut
strafrechtigen Entscheidung es gab ja
auch Betrugsvorwürfe gegen sie die haben
sie ja entkräften wollen er lassen Sie
uns noch ganz kurz auf ihre Tätigkeit
bisher im Europäischen Parlament kommen
da wird möglicherweise jetzt helle
Freude ausbrechen in der Fraktion
Identität und Demokratie wenn sie als
Leiter der Delegation schon als
Spitzenkandidat kommen weil sie sind ja
auch eine Zeit lang suspendiert worden
aus der Fraktion in der Fraktion weil
sie einen politischen Gegner ihrer
Parteifreundin Marine Le Pen in bei der
französischen Präsidentschaftswahl
unterstützt haben ist das die Art wie
sie Loyalität buchstabieren also erstens
wird die helle Freude nicht nur ironisch
sondern tatsächlich ausbrechen weil man
endlich die Hoffnung hat dass die AFD in
Russland mit derselben Stimme spricht
wie in Berlin und das war leider mit
Leuten und seinem Nachfolger nicht mehr
gegeben sondern wir haben jetzt Klarheit
geschaffen die Russland AFD und die
Bundestagsfraktion Bundespartei stimmen
überein ansonsten habe ich niemals auch
wenn das ein parteipolitischer Gegner
von mir behauptet in der Verteiler
Wahlkampf gegen Marine gemacht sondern
ich habe im Rahmen eines einstündigen
Vortrages beide Kandidaten
vorgestellt
und man hat dann innerhalb der deutschen
Delegation gemeint man müsse da
irgendwie etwas konstruieren es gab
diesbezüglich nie Ärger mit unseren
französischen Freunden und sie sehen ja
auch wenn sie mich auf Social Media
verfolgen dass ich sehr gut mit den
Franzosen und ist zwar mit den
Italienern zusammenarbeitet das heißt
diese diese falschen Anschuldigung die
kann man vielleicht auf anonym Telegramm
Gruppen verbreiten aber ich finde doch
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk brauchen
wir das nicht da ist nichts dran das ist
Unsinn und dummes Zeug das haben sie
jetzt so aus ihrer Sicht geschildert in
jedem Fall kann man jetzt aus ihrer Rede
lernen die sich hier gehalten haben dass
es mit ihnen möglicherweise ziemlich
turbulent werden könnte im Europäischen
Parlament in der neuen Legislaturperiode
ich bedanke mich ja gut sie haben mir
angekündigt Entschuldigung sie haben ja
angekündigt dass sie die Interessen
Deutschlands ganz klar vertreten werden
in einer Leidenschaftlichkeit in einem
Tonfall wo man doch denkt da kannst
durchaus turbulent werden im
Europäischen Parlament ich glaube dass
jeder deutsche Politiker die Interessen
Deutschland und der deutschen Wähler mit
Leidenschaft vertreten soll und dass sie
allein das für Alleinstellungsmerkmal
haben sagt viele über unseren
derzeitigen Höhenflug aus sie haben
Recht die Ampel und die CDU vertreten
Deutschland Interessen nicht
Mitleidenschaft deshalb braucht sie AFD
das haben wir jetzt zu Ende genommen von
Maximilian gerade dem Spitzenkandidaten
der AFD für die Wahl zum Europäischen
Parlament im Juni 2024 im Wahlkampf
werden wir sie häufiger sehen und ihr
Gesicht uns merken danke dass Sie hier
waren